[Music]
it is the bestselling book in history no
volume ever written has been more loved
and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions our phone lines are open if
you have a Bible related question give
us a call now at 800 God says that's 800
7297 now here's your host from amazing
fax International Pastor Doug Bachelor
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact about cloves
cloves are a basic spice that you can
buy in any Supermarket for about $3 and
they're used to spice up cookies cakes
and even flavor Worster sauce but these
dried flower buds have quite literally
altered the course of history cloves are
more than just a flavoring they contain
a good mix of vitamins and minerals and
have some medicinal properties as a
natural painkiller or to settle a
stomach but in the 16th century cloves
were thought to be the cure for almost
everything and used to treat a wide
range of ailments including intestinal
distress impotence diarrhea vomiting and
chalera in fact cloves were so precious
they were literally worth more than
their weight in gold at one time the
only place in the world that you could
get cloes was in the Mala islands off of
Indonesia wars were fought nations were
formed and thousands perished in an
effort to control the spice trade it was
in pursuit of a shorter route to these
Spice Islands that the fleet of
Ferdinand melan became the first
expedition to circumnavigate the Earth
in 1519 melan set out with five ships
carrying about 270 men heading for the
malakas 3 years later only one leaking
ship came limping home with 18 starving
crew members incredibly The Voyage still
made money because of the Fantastic
value of the few cloves they brought
with them it's hard to imagine people
willing to die for an herb in your spice
cabinet you might be surprised to know
the Bible says that a few words of
scripture are worth much more than
cloves or gold Pastor Ross makes me
think about those verses in the Bible
and this is just a sampling of a few
Psalms
119 the law of your mouth is better to
me than thousands of coins of gold and
silver or you look in Proverbs 8:
8-10 receive my instruction and not
silver and knowledge rather than Choice
gold for wisdom is better than rubies
and all things that one might desire
cannot be compared with her and then of
course you get what is it psalm 19 the
law of the Lord is sweeter than honey
and the honeycomb more desired to are
they then gold much fine gold and so um
yeah it's kind of incredible I've been
reading history and I think you and I
have been sharing some of these history
books of H how people would fight and
die for these herbs that we just kind of
sprinkle on our food and a fact during
the Roman era they paid people with salt
that's where we get the word salary
but um the word of God is worth more
than silver gold or any of those things
absolutely you know the talk about these
herbs and cloes and how they felt that
it preserved uh you know your physical
life but the word of God preserves your
spiritual life so it is more valuable it
lasts not just for this life but in
eternity we have a study guide talking
about the Bible how do you understand
the Bible can you trust the Bible it's
one of our amazing fact study guides
it's called is there anything left you
can trust trust and this is our free
gift to anyone who calls and asks the
number is 800 835 6747 you can ask for
offering number3 or ask for it by name
it's called is there anything left you
can trust you can also order this by
dialing pound 250 on your smartphone and
just say Bible answers live and then ask
for it it's called anything left you can
trust we'll be happy to send it to
anyone in North America if you're
outside of the US or outside of North
America just go to the website
amazingfacts O G amen well we're ready
to go to the phone lines but before we
take our first caller let's start with
prayer dear father we are grateful that
we have this time to be able to open up
your word and indeed it is precious it
is powerful it's more valuable than
anything that we have here on this Earth
for it is the word of life and so we ask
your blessing as we study together be
with those who are listening lead us
into a clearer understanding of your
word for we ask this in Jesus name amen
amen our first caller this evening we've
got Britany list listening in California
Britney welcome to Bible answers
live hi Britney you
there we might have to come back she may
be on mute we'll try someone else here
we've got Sharon in Oregon Sharon
welcome to Bible answers
live good morning or good evening
pastors um I have a question on
Revelation chapter 11 MH and I
understand that the two witnesses are
the old New Testament but when it gets
to verse 11 through 14 it doesn't sound
like it's talking about the same thing
when they stand on their feet and then
God calls them to Heaven they ascend in
a cloud can you explain that part yeah
the the whole passage here about the two
witnesses and I think it is a United
passage when it says they finished their
testimony some have described it as the
new and the Old Testament or you might
say the law and the prophets because you
have these two witnesses that appear to
Jesus on the Mount of transfiguration
Moses and Elijah they represent the word
of God Moses the great lawgiver Elijah
the great prophet last words in the Old
Testament are remember the law of Moses
behold I send you Elijah the prophet and
this is an attack on the word of God
which is duel in nature New and Old
Testament Ten Commandments have two
tables of stone and so it's a sword with
two edges and so then it says that when
they finish their t testimony the Beast
that ascends out of the bottom of this
pit and make war on them but you're
wondering about in verse 11 it says
after 3 and a half days the Breath of
Life enters them and they stood on their
feet the word of God while it's talking
about kind of resurrected stands back up
again they've been dead and uh it says
three and a half days a day is like a
year this is talking about an attack on
the word of God and the religion of
Christ uh during the French Revolution
where they basically they even went from
from a 7-Day week to a 10-day week
because they said that uh the only place
you can trace a 7-Day week to is the
Bible and bibles were burned and there's
a big outcry France basically became the
first atheist
nation and but after the reign of terror
three and a half years later things had
just so imploded that they sheepishly
reallowed the Bible to come back into
the country and Napoleon kind the good
and bad of Napoleon one of the things is
he did then allow freedom of religion
where before the Christians were
terribly persecuted that three and a
half year period has been described as
November 10 1793 that's when they passed
the decree in the French assembly um
outlawing the Bible and the Bibles were
piled up and burnt in the street but
exactly 3 and a half years later June 17
1798 they o overturned that decree they
reversed the decree allowing the word of
God and freedom in the word of God you
know it's also interesting Pastor D that
voler one of these famous atheistic
authors who scuffed at the Bible he made
a statement and said you know within
this generation the Bible would be an
extinct book nobody would even pay any
attention to it and you know he
published his writings and he had a
printing press the amazing thing is that
just uh you know decades later not very
long later uh The Bible Society ended up
being set up and they used the very
printing press that Vol used to
propagate his atheistic views his same
printing press was used to print the
Bible mhm so indeed the word of God was
lifted up and magnified and of course
this brings you into the early 1800s
where there was a great Revival in Bible
truth missionaries were sent around the
world the Bible was being translating in
all kinds of languages thus it was
lifted up and elied
yeah you know we have a book called The
Ultimate resource and it's all about the
Bible and you might enjoy the Sharon or
anyone who is watching or listening just
again the number to call is 8835 6747
you can ask for that book it's called
the ultimate resource you can also dial
pound 250 on your smartphone say Bible
answers live and then ask for the book
by name the ultimate resource we got uh
let's go back to Britany Britney in
California Britney are you
there Britany in
California all right our connection is
not working let's go to Ryan in New
Mexico Ryan you on the
air yes sir is it Pastor Jan and Pastor
Doug yes oh EX nice to actually hear
hear you guys that's is so awesome um my
question is um I've been doing a little
bit of research on the the different you
know calendars as far as the Sabbath and
the L the lunar Sabbath um you know I my
question is did Jesus use two different
calendars the Julian calendar and the
moon you know um I just I see a lot I
get you know from the scriptures I see
more evidence as far as it being the the
new moon day you know as far as you know
when they started their six working days
but then there was a new moon day you
know um does that make sense um I guess
Jesus used two calendar calendars I'm
sorry no I think I understand what
you're saying is and just for friends
who are listening the Jews did use a
lunar calendar their months were
controlled by the moon but the weekly
Sabbath which came every seven days was
a completely distinct uh cycle of time
sometimes we look at a calendar which
registers both the month and the week
and we think that they're conjoined
they're not it's just one piece of paper
that's showing us two distinct cycles of
time the 7-Day week dates back to Adam
you know God rested on the seventh day
and he blessed the seventh day and every
seventh day those would follow God they
kept honoring that as a Sabbath God
reinstituted that that um for the
children of Israel when they came back
out of Egypt even before they got to
Mount Si God told them I'm going to give
you bread from heaven six days a week
seventh day there'll be none gathered
twice as much on what we would call
Friday the the sixth day and so that
that cycle has been in uh continuity
from the time of creation to the present
day um it is true the Jews had a
calendar with 360 days but the new moon
would fall on different days of the week
uh all throughout the year it had
nothing to do with a weekly cycle so
just keep the two separate in your mind
there's no problem and of course the the
Luna month as you mentioned that was
used for some of the ceremonial days
right because they start counting and
then there were certain ceremonial days
that fell on certain times of of the
week could be on different days that was
considered a Sabbath in other words they
would often keep those those ceremonial
days as the Sabbath but that was always
distinct from the seventh day Sabbath
right and every now and then when you
had a lunar Sabbath land on the weekly
Sabbath they call it a High Sabbath or
if you had a an annual Feast Sabbath
like the Passover tells us in the Bible
when it fell on the Sabbath day they
called it a High Sabbath but they're two
distinct uh cycles of time just like
your birthday might be on a different
day of the week every year right all
right well thanks for your call Ryan
we've got James in Texas James welcome
to Bible answers live yes good evening
pastors hi
evening yes my question for the night
would be has the latter rain happened
because of so so many predictions by
pastors because I've I've watched some
my YouTube and stuff like that and
everybody's all talking about them on
they've still already seen visions and
stuff like that yeah no I I don't think
the latter rign and let me just explain
for those listening what we're talking
about uh the Jews in their agriculture
culture their uh farming uh language
they would have one rain that would come
to sprout the seed they call that the
former or the first rain then before the
Harvest they would have a latter or last
rain that would then ripen the crop for
Harvest those terms are used for the
outpouring of the spirit when Christ
came he told the disciples to wait in
Jerusalem and he said you'll re receive
that refreshing and the uh Power of the
Holy Spirit fell on them during
Pentecost that is the former Reign
before Christ comes there's promises
that you read both in the Book of Joel
and in the book of Acts that God is
going to pour out his Spirit on All
Flesh and so the question is has that
happened yet I do not think so uh
because we've not seen the evidence of
the spirit and the power and the gospel
spreading and mostly the Holiness I
think that's one of the real signs
you'll have is there'll be just a a real
a love and a Holiness among God's people
and the power of Miracles I mean real
Miracles that we just have not seen so a
lot of people are saying oh I had a
vision and a lot of pastors are saying
oh this is the outpouring of the spirit
I don't think we've seen anything like
Pentecost yet I think it's going to be
evident when it happens yeah we have a
verse Zechariah 10:1 it says ask the
Lord for rain in the time of the latter
rain and the Lord will make flashing
clouds and give them showers of rain
grass in the field for everyone so here
we have a special
prayer for the latter Reign a special
outpouring of the Holy Spirit and as you
said Pastor Doug the the former Reign
that took place at Pentecost was the
seed that helped Sprout the gospel
throughout the world but there is a
final ripening that has to take place
before Jesus comes before the Harvest
that's right and the Bible speaks of
this special outpouring of the Holy
Spirit we want to be ready when that
time comes amen that we might be ones
who receive the latter rain we have a
book I just thought of it it's called
life in the spirit it's about the Holy
Spirit and living uh preparing for that
latter rain if you'd like to receive it
the number to call is 800 83567 47 you
can ask for the book it's called life in
the spirit you can also dial pound 250
on your smartphone say Bible answers
live and ask for the book a life in the
spirit we've got Oliver in St Louis
Missouri Oliver welcome to the
program hi good evening pastors and
thank you for the call um my question is
about uh the in P the Panorama of
Prophecy series Pastor Doug you were um
referring to and uh talking about uh the
passage in Revelation that talks about
how at Jesus's second coming every eye
will see him and addressing specifically
the part where uh since the world is
around how exactly does that happen
physically and you're mentioning that
technically um not every eye it doesn't
say every eye will see him at the same
time that he could be doing a sweep of
the world as he enters and that could be
people could see him I guess in sequence
as he goes around am I understanding
correctly yeah and by the way the verse
is in Revelation 1:7 and it's also in
Matthew 24 it says that all in Matthew
24 it says all the tribes of the earth
will mourn and they will see the son of
man coming and then here in Revelation 1
it says behold is coming with the clouds
and every eye will see him and so uh
some have wondered well if the world's
round how does everybody see him at the
same time well I don't think the verse
is saying everybody sees him
simultaneously I think it's saying the
day of the Lord when he does come and it
says you know he sends forth his angels
to the four corners of the earth uh and
Christ is going to I believe make a
circuit around the earth and we are
caught up to meet him in the air as he
does that everybody in the world will
see him but it doesn't mean at the same
moment MH absolutely we've got a study
guide talking about the second coming
it's called the ultimate deliverance and
we'll be happy to send it to anyone who
calls and asks very exciting and
important study it's all about the
second coming the ultimate Deliverance
the number is 800 83567 47 or you can
dial pound 250 ask for the study guide
by name ultimate Deliverance amen thank
you we've got Henry in New York Henry
welcome to the
program yes Pastor J my question is um
so people who are born mentally
sick
mentally if they if they die at the age
of 90 years old they still mentally sck
if they do certain things will God hold
against
them yeah well God is a loving God Henry
and so if a person has some kind of
mental handicap uh you know he he may
judge many of them as you would a child
before the age of account accountability
and they would be saved and the Bible
says that to whom much is given much is
required if a person is given little
little is required and some people um
they just don't understand and Jesus
said people are judged because they do
understand and they ignore the truth he
said if you were blind you would have no
sin but now you say we see or we
understand he says your sin remains so
people who they're handicapped in some
way and they just can't understand God
is a merciful god and so we never have
to worry about will God be fair God he's
the very epitome of Justice right very
good Oscar listening in uh New York
Oscar welcome to the
program yes
sir the the Bible says that God is a
consuming fire so my question is this is
the Lake of Fire in the Book of
Revelation
God no when it yeah when it says that uh
God is a consuming fire that's talking
about um you know he's got a shakina
Gloria presence and it says a a fire
devours before him the Bible tells us
that the wicked when Christ comes the
wicked are destroyed by the brightness
the glory of his coming um it's almost
like when I was a kid we would sometimes
play with a magnifying glass on a summer
day and it wasn't very nice but we'd
burn ants and just the magnification of
just that light was enough to just burn
up the ants well the glory of God is
going to be bright but it will not hurt
the righteous but it will destroy the
wicked now separate from the lake of
fire because the Bible says these are
separated from God it's they are Cast
Away they are cast into the Lake of Fire
so the Lake of Fire where the wicked are
consumed and devoured that is not the
the God's of Glory it is like Lake of
Fire like the fire and brimstone burn up
Sodom and Gomorrah and in Revelation
chapter 20 we read about what's called
the Great White Throne judgment
describes the wicked outside of the New
Jerusalem the righteous are inside the
city and there is a final judgment and
they can actually see God so he must
Veil his glory somehow during that
judgment time and then the wed Mount
their attack upon the New Jerusalem and
then fire comes down from heaven and
devours them when it talks here in
Revelation 20:15 anyone not found
written in the Book of Life was cast
into the Lake of Fire so again you've
got God the father or the glory of God
some are veiled because the wicked are
not destroyed and yet there is the Lake
of Fire in which they are cast at the
end of that judgment yeah and that final
judgment is not God's light or Glory
because it says they are cast into outer
Darkness where there's weeping and
nashing of teeth so it's a different uh
punishment that you see there but good
question thank you Henry we got Chris
Christiana in Florida Christina rather
sorry Christine Christina welcome to the
two Bible answers
live hi good evening
evening question I have a yes um I have
a question will we be able to see God
when we go to heaven because there is a
lot of different conflicting things in
the Bible for example 1 Timothy chapter
6 verse 16 says that you know no one
will ever see God and will never be able
to see him but Moses saw God's back and
then there's another verse that says
blessed are those that are righteous for
they'll see God and then there's another
verse that says we would be consumed if
we saw God because we're so sinful so
when we get to heaven will we actually
be able to see God well the the simple
answer is yes and my verse is revelation
224 last chapter in the Bible says they
will see his face speaking of the saved
now right now we cannot see God the
father because the glory as I mentioned
would just it would consume us and even
God told Moses who is Holy no man can
see my face his unveiled glory in their
present condition now Moses is in the
presence of God with a glorified body
now I'm sure he does see God's face and
in in heaven you know God used to walk
in the garden with Adam and Eve they saw
god um the times in the Old Testament
where it says they saw God they probably
saw what we call a christophany which is
it's Christ before the Incarnation they
saw God the son so anytime it says you
and even Jesus said no man can see the
father and that's probably one of the
verses you're referring to Christina
so uh when it says that they can't see
the father it's talking about man in his
Fallen condition uh cannot see the face
of God the Father we do see Jesus Christ
said if you've seen me you've seen the
father it's you know veiled in humanity
but um in heaven it's as clear as it can
be we will see his face God himself will
dwell with
us okay thank you thanks good question
we' got Justin in Wisconsin Justin
welcome to Bible answers live
hi my question is how do you keep the
Commandments how do you keep them well
Jesus says if you love me the the the
best way to keep the Commandments is
because you love God I was just reading
today Pastor Ross you know I'm starting
a new Bible reading program and I'm in
Genesis where Jacob U is working for
Rachel he's got to work seven years the
Bible says he loved her so much it
seemed like
days uh the work seemed like nothing
because of the love that he had for
Rachel and the more we love the Lord any
good works or obedience is just it's an
act of love we want to do the things
that please him so if we're struggling
to obey the question is how do we love
God more the Bible tells us that um we
love him because he first loved us so
when we see and we behold Christ's love
for us in his life and on the cross it
moves our hearts and we love him and
want to serve him that verse you're
referring to is John 14:15 where Jesus
says if you love me keep my Commandments
and we love him because he first loved
us we need to Behold Him we Behold Him
through his word Pastor that you
mentioned you started a new Bible
reading plan while I read the very same
passage of scripture cuz we're probably
on the same plan and we just want to
encourage people what a great
opportunity here we are at the beginning
of the year if you're not on a Bible
reading plan you need to get on one I
mean it it doesn't take long actually if
you read the Bible over a year just
divide it up you could probably read
your daily portion within 10 15 minutes
so it doesn't take long there's even
apps that will read the Bible to you and
help you stay on track so we would just
really want to encourage people to take
advantage beginning of a new year set of
goal of reading through the Bible in
2024 and they'd appreciate the lesson we
offered to everybody about the Bible is
there anything left you can trust the
number for that is 800 835 6747 you can
ask for the study guide anything left
you can trust or do pound 250 on your
smartphone say Bible ansers live and
amazing facts does actually have just
thought of it now a Bible reading plan
if you don't have one of course you can
get one for free online or you can just
simply go to amazing facts and find out
about the free Bible reading plan yep
that we have okay next caller that we
have is Cedric in Florida Cedric welcome
to the
program thank you pastors Pastor dog
Pastor yes is a this is a question for
Pastor Doug what is your opinion on the
people who are created and still
buried cremated and still buried uh I'm
not sure what you mean cremated and
buried so you mean if they're cremated
and then they're buried does that affect
the resurrection or no but um I'm say
that um that is POS that people are some
people are created and and they're not
scattered the is being buried oh I see
what you're saying in Yeah Yeah well
yeah and matter of fact that's what
happened with my grandparents is they
they were cremated and then they have a
cemetery they've got a wall that's full
of
NS and uh people do that economically
because it saves space compared to a
whole coffin but um you know I don't
think there's really any difference the
Bible tells us ashes to ashes and dust
to dust so it's not a problem for God to
resurrect now uh technically if you say
what is the Bible method for disposing
of dead or how do you treat the dead um
almost 99% of the time it's burial you
know Abraham was buried Isaac was buried
Joseph was buried they were in baled but
then they were buried only one or two
examples in the Bible of a believer that
was cremated now many of the martyrs who
died for their faith they were burned at
the stake well they're certainly going
to be resurrected so cremation does not
pre prevent God from resurrecting you
then folks have argued you know now with
the so many people in the world all the
space taken up by cemeteries how can we
keep doing this you know I don't know
that there it's a what's the word for it
I don't know that it's a a saved lost
question but biblically if you want to
know what they did it was typically
burial that's right you know the Bible
does talk about a couple of examples
where a Believer as far as we know was
burnt you have 1st Samuel 31:12 talks
about the bones of Jonathan after his
death were gathered and they were burnt
and of course we believe that Jonathan
will be saved he was a good man and
he'll be in heaven and you know during
during the Reformation some of the
martyrs like Whitfield are are Wickliffe
they scatter their ashes in the river
and they thought that'll prevent this
friend you hear the music we're just
taking a break we're going to come back
with more Bible answers don't go
anywhere stay tuned Bible answers live
will return
[Music]
shortly
would you like to have unlimited free
access to a library of resources that'll
help answer your most important
questions about the Bible amazing facts
has a huge collection of faith-building
books covering a whole spectrum of
topics you can download and read
wherever you are in multiple languages
to enjoy our Free Library visit
amazingfacts.org click on the Bible
study Tab and choose free book Library
do you feel as though your world is
spiraling out of control or perhaps new
life challenges are frightening you more
than they should are you sinking while
you're thinking excessive worry can
consume you eating you from the inside
out resulting in sickness insomnia and
paralyzing fear it can also damage
relationships ruin opportunities and yes
diminish your witness for the gospel
worry affects everybody differently but
it's all driven by fear so how can you
overcome a world full of reasons to be
anxious I'd like to recommend for you my
new book Finding peace in a world of
worry you'll discover a Lifeline to
Victory a place where you can cast your
cares upon Christ and experience a
Serenity that isn't subject to your
circumstances send a gift of any amount
to receive your copy of Pastor Doug's
new book Finding peace in a world of
worry call
one today Jerusalem the city of Peace
has been a place of unending Conflict
for centuries many now believe that
Jerusalem will soon take Center Stage
again but what does the Bible say the
fall and Rise of Jerusalem presents the
vital history you need to know about
Jerusalem and its role in end time Bible
prophecy this amazing facts edition of
the classic volume the great controversy
is the perfect sharing book get your
copy at AF bookstore.com
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life
today if you have a question about the
Bible or living the Christian Life call
us now at 800 God says that's 8004 46
37297 now let's rejoin our hosts for
more Bible answers
live welcome back listening friends to
Bible answers live you may not only be
listening friends you might be watching
friends you could be watching us on AFV
or on 3abn we do the replays there or uh
one of the other broadcasts Good News
Network we welcome you you can also
watch on Facebook live we're
broadcasting Live on YouTube amazing
facts YouTube Doug Bachelor uh Facebook
page and uh for those who are tuning in
this is a live International interactive
Bible study and we take your phone calls
and with very little warning we do our
best to answer your questions so
sometimes our our screeners will put up
a little note here and says they've got
a question on the Trinity or whatever it
is and and then we just uh pray for
wisdom and look at the word of God and
answer your questions so uh if you have
a question you can call us 800 God says
that's 8004 6
37297 I am Doug Bachelor my name is Jean
Ross and we've got Jason standing by in
Washington Jason welcome to Bible ances
live hi thank you thank you for your
program my question is uh well first I'm
an atheist and my question is a lot of
times when I when I talk with Christians
and I sort of back them into a into a
corner because we we can't understand
why God does something and a lot of
times they'll say well you know we're
just humans and we can't understand God
so I was I was calling to ask
specifically what is it about the human
brain that doesn't allow us to
understand God because I think there
isn't anything missing in the human
brain that would allow us to understand
god well I think first of all I'm
delighted to talk to you I used to be an
atheist too and um I got to where I just
didn't have enough Faith to be an
atheist because it to me there is I
can't find any evidence in the
observable universe where you get Inner
working systems organization and design
by chance there's always intelligence
invested in those things uh now I think
we can understand something about the
mind of God and in the Bible God says
come now let us reason together and
there's a lot of evidence we see in the
world of you know just the symbiotic
relationship between creatures and
plants and animals um just incredible
inredible cycle of you know we exhale
what the plants inhale so to speak and
so there's there's a lot we understand
from God both in his word and in the
observable
universe um you know i' I'd love to see
you read my book uh you can actually
listen to the testimony for free online
it's called the richest caveman and it
tells you why I went from being an
atheist or at least an agnostic to
believing in the Bible
and I thought that would never happen
but um yeah it's I don't know if I'm
answering your question
though no you're not okay you you want
to know what in our human Minds would
prevent us from understanding the will
of
God yeah well see I think we can
understand the will of
God so I'm having a problem with the
question um I I I think his word to
sorry go ahead well I I guess it doesn't
apply to you maybe it just applies to
Christians who who think they can't
because this is the problem I I run up a
lot when I talk with Christians well no
I In fairness there's a lot of things
that happen we don't understand I mean
we see a tragedy where some innocent
person suffers and we think of God is
good why does that happen now to some
extent we do understand those things and
a lot of Christians don't they don't um
explain it very well but there is a
battle that is going on between good and
evil not only is there a good loving God
but the highest of his creation was a
creature called Lucifer that rebelled
and came to this world and said I can
run things better and our first parents
they listen to Lucifer instead of God
and basically he hijacked the planet and
there's a lot of forces at play here
that are in the Bible people don't talk
about so a lot of the evil that we see
in the world is not God's will that's
why Jesus said we should pray thy will
be done because a lot of things God
doesn't want to happen so when we see
things we don't understand you know we
can't see into the spiritual realm just
like we can't see radio
waves uh but they're very real and of
course we mentioned earlier we do have a
a study guide that talks about the Bible
and if you believe the Bible and there's
plenty of evidence to support the Bible
that it is a trustworthy book it is a
revelation and if you read the Bible you
understand more of this great
controversy you understand what God is
like and you understand the Plan of
Redemption and what God did to save
mankind so again that is a great
resource for anyone wanting to learn
more it's called the ultimate resource
and you can just call and ask the number
is
8835 6747 ask for that study guide call
the ultimate resource you can also dial
pound 250 just say Bible answers live
and then the ultimate resource all right
thank you Jason we've got Grace in
California Grace welcome to the
program yes thank you good evening
Pastor D and Pastor Rose
evening my question is is it okay for a
student to take yoga classes in
college yeah well yoga you know I used
to be involved in Eastern religions and
and yoga was sort of a combination of
you know body exercises procedures
cleansing and um it was sort of
combining the body and the spirit but it
was woven into the the mysticism of the
religion so for me I would not be
comfortable doing that I I sto short of
condemning people that are doing yoga
exercises for purely physical
reasons um but in know in its beginning
uh yoga is very much tied to a religious
belief and there's other great exercises
besides yoga classes
I don't know if that helps a little hope
hope that makes sense Grace thank you
we've got Christian in Texas Christian
welcome to the
program hello I just want to make sure
you hear me we do loud and
clear okay so my question is in Job
chapter one uh how did Satan get into
the presence of God and the angels if he
was kicked out of heaven well first of
all the Bible doesn't say this meeting
was in heaven it says there was a day
when the sons of God came to present
themselves before the Lord and job also
the devil came among them and this is in
Job chapter 1 uh so you know God God
left Heaven every now and then for
instance when he walked with Adam and
Eve in the garden he went other places
to visit his creatures and his creation
and so wherever this meeting is it
doesn't say in the Bible Satan is able
to access this meeting and I don't know
that the devil was completely
confined to the Earth until after the
time of the cross I Think Jesus said I
beheld Satan fall like lightning from
heaven so
um I think that up to that point he was
able to
still um accuse you see him in the book
of Zechariah he's standing before the
Lord accusing the high priest when it
says that the devil was Satan was cast
out of Heaven it's not necessarily
meaning that he can never go back for a
meeting or something like that but it
means that was no longer his home yeah
he was cast out of Heaven The Dwelling
Place of God so wherever the meeting
took place if it was in heaven well the
devil came for a specific reason he
claimed the Earth was his and he was
representing the Earth that's why God
said where did you come from and he said
oh from walking up and down on the earth
so he claimed the Earth as his quite
possibly the sons of God that we read
about there in job are representatives
of other intelligent worlds of unfallen
beings the devil claims the Earth Is His
so you have the story there recorded in
job and just to add to that Revelation
chap 12 talks about the devil being cast
out of heaven and that took place before
creation but then it also says at the
cross the devil was cast down and as you
mentioned at the cross now Jesus is the
representative of the earth so the devil
is now bound to this Earth yeah you know
one more thing occurred to me while
you're talking is that um you know here
in our world I can talk to people I did
it today on the other side of the planet
and What Makes Us think that the devil
had to actually be standing in front of
God to talk to God if if we've got cell
phon and internet then the devil can
communicate with God uh no matter where
he is but uh I think this one it does
imply in the Book of Job he came into
the presence he showed up but thank you
all right next caller that we have is
Natasha in New York Natasha welcome to
the
program hi thank you so much hi Pastor
dog hi get real close to your phone I'm
sorry that's better thank
you okay um okay so my question is um
it's based
on uh Mark
95 um I saw that well I read that um
that Moses and Elijah they made a cameo
appearance in the New Testament and I
was wondering about Enoch because I
never since God took Enoch I never saw I
never read about him again so I just
wanted your to hear your thoughts on it
good question thank you I'll listen yeah
good good question you know the Bible
tells us not only did Elijah go to
heaven without dying but Enoch walked
with God and he was not for God took him
why was it only Moses and Elijah that
appeared on the Mount of transfiguration
that you find in Mark chapter 9 UM and
by the way that's also in Luke and in
Matthew I think it's because that for
that particular
experience um Moses and Elijah had a
relationship with Jesus different from
Enoch's both both Moses and Elijah
fasted 40 days and 40 nights as Jesus
did Moses represents the Law Elijah
represents the prophets um Enoch might
have been beholding from the front row
we don't know but just Moses and Elijah
came to
appear basically symbolizing the law and
the prophets that endorsed that Jesus
was the Messiah and also we have a
miniature of the second coming there
Jesus said you know just 6 days after he
said to his disciples you shall see the
son of man six days before six days
before that yes and then of course
Elijah represents those who are alive
when Jesus comes and are translated to
heaven without seeing death and Moses
who died and was resurrected could
represent those who are resurrected at
the second coming of Christ so it's
really rather significant that you have
those two appearing with Jesus on the
Mount of transfiguration it's a
miniature picture of the second coming
we actually have a book called It's
called the two witnesses the two
witnesses that's right and it's free
we'll send it to anyone who calls and
asks the number is 800 8356 747 ask for
the book called the two witnesses also
you can Dial Dial pound 250 and ask for
that say Bible answers live and then ask
for the two witnesses we've got John
listening in Arizona John welcome to the
program yeah is that Arizona or Arkansas
Arkansas you're
correct yeah well I listened to uh
Pastor do response
to the return of the Lord in uh
Revelations 1 7 uhhuh but then in
Matthew
24:27 it says as Lightning cometh out of
the East and flashes even unto the West
I'm I'm of the opinion I'm asking for a
comment on this that because I know
lightning will travel around the
Earth seven times in a second at the
speed of
light and he said from east to west as
the lightning
flashes and it would seem logical that
every would see him in within that
second yeah well I think that when Jesus
talks about his second coming being as
Lightning he's not emphasizing the speed
of light he's emphasizing that everyone
will see and it will not be a secret
because when lightning flashes across
the sky you don't have to Elbow the
person next to you and say did you see
that uh so he's actually addressing the
idea that his coming would be a secret
and he said it's not a secret it would
be like lightning that covers the
Heavens he's not saying that his coming
would sweep around the heaven in the
blink of an eye and he'd be done with it
so uh at least that's my understanding
but you make a good point he says it'll
go from the East to the West he's
talking about it traveling from point A
to point B Jesus is coming from the East
and he's going to sweep around the world
uh from the you know going west and head
back to well not only that Pastor that
would you also have the earth that is
still turning when Jesus is coming so as
Christ approaches the Earth and the
Earth keeps turning well at 24 hours the
Earth has made a full rotation everybody
has seen Jesus coming that's true even
before he sweeps around the earth as
he's approaching the Earth everyone will
see him that's true yeah okay great
question than even if he stood still
everyone would eventually see him 24
hours yeah the Earth turns we got Ryan
in New Mexico Ryan welcome to the
program hello again hi um I have an I
have a different question this time um
basically whenever I'm talking about uh
the Bible and you know uh basically uh
the the difference between the law of
Moses and the Ten Commandments um is
were the two tablets were made out were
they made out of blue sapphire you know
because Yahweh you know wrote on him
with his finger do you know what I mean
and they kept them them on the inside of
the Ark of the Covenant and then they
had the law of Moses uh you know written
on paper by Moses um you know what I'm
saying and kept on the outside of the
Ark um yeah you you can go on from there
oh but yeah Blue Sapphire were they made
out of blue sapphire um yeah some people
conjecture that the Ten Commandments
were written on Blue Sapphire because
Sapphire is one of the stones that's
mentioned as a pavement around God's
throne but there's no scripture so I all
I would do is speculate uh and you know
I got to tell you if it's if I don't
have a command that says and this law
was written on Sapphire I can't tell you
who it was just says two tables of stone
now evidently whatever that stone was it
must have been available in the desert
there because when Moses broke the first
tables of stone God told them to Hue two
more tables of stone like the first and
bring them up so nothing is said about
the value of the stone it could have
been plain granite or some stone that
was abundant probably hard that was
found there in the desert but not so
hard that you you know couldn't CH I
guess God could chisel than anything but
anyway it never says it was Sapphire uh
we've got a member of our church that um
cuts um Stone and he made us a beautiful
set of Ten Commandments on a bluish
Granite because he thinks it's Sapphire
also might be we don't know so there's
no command no specific scripture yeah
and that's a good question was there um
sapphire in that region in in the desert
and it must have been a large piece of
sapphire can you you know do you find
that big of sapphire stone I don't know
maybe yeah any I can't wait to find out
Ryan yeah all right we got Donna in
Canada Donna welcome to the
program thank you so much and uh nice to
talk to you finally I see you on TV all
the time but I've never spoken with you
so anyway Don can I ask you a question
sure um what do you mind my asking what
channel do you watch
on um um let me
think well I watched the amazing facts
Channel and ABN 38n nwor okay good good
I I just I didn't want to trip you up I
just we always like to find out how are
people seeing the program all right your
your question then
sorry okay I'm trying to study the Bible
and I have to tell you I've never been
interested in history I've never been
interested in
politics um I don't have a clue about
either of those things and as I'm
reading Daniel I think it's Daniel 11
it's talking about the King of the North
and the King of the South and he talking
about all these different countries and
I don't it sounds like a foreign
language to me so I just wondered if you
had any books or whatever or literature
that might explain these things great
question uh you know I think I should
mention that Pastor Ross right now is
doing a class every week or almost every
week going through Daniel and he's just
getting ready to to dive into Daniel 11
do not be discouraged Donna that you
don't understand all of the political
Intrigue that is happening in Daniel 11
it is a challenge it's one of the most
challenging prophetic chapters in The
Bible but very simply you've got a
battle between uh it says the King of
the North and the king in the South that
uh starts out with the southern powers
of the Greek Empire and and the northern
powers of the Greek Empire and then that
kind of transitions over history
how those transitions play out there's
quite a bit of discussion on I don't
know Pastor Ross you got lessons coming
out yeah we do we actually going to be
talking about that in a couple of weeks
so you know if you want to tune in I
think it's on YouTube you can you can
Hilltop yeah it is interesting you've
got as you mentioned Pastor D the King
of the North Begins with um the Assyrian
the Syrian Powers part of the Grecian
Empire and you have the King of the
South bomy would be the the lineage and
the king of Egypt eventually the king of
Egypt is subdued by the King of the
North which would be the Grecian power
uh uh there's different kings that come
and go but they all fall under the the
king of the north but then Rome conquers
the Greeks and Rome becomes the king of
the north right and very interesting as
a place even to both Rome in its pagan
form and also in its papal form you get
to around verse 40 it brings you right
up to our time so yeah there's a lot
there yeah great question Donna keep
studying you'll you'll uh it'll get
clear all right we got Lloyd in uh
Arkansas Lloyd welcome to the
program uh thank you very much for uh
listening to me
yes uh my question is can you explain to
me Psalms chapter 2 verse 7 and Hebrews
chapter 5 verse5 what is taking place
there and who's doing the talking to
whom great all right let me read it for
our friends if you go to Psalms the
second psalm in verse 7 says I will
declare the decree the Lord has said to
me you are my son today I have begotten
you ask of me I want to read verse eight
also ask of me and I will give you the
Nations for your inheritance and the
ends of the Earth for your possession so
when you get to the New Testament we see
that this is um this is a prophecy of
Jesus and if you look in Hebrews 1
verse5 it says for to which of the
Angels did a say you are my son Paul
assuming Paul wrote Hebrews Paul is
saying this is a prophecy about Jesus
he's not talking about angels being his
son and David when it says my Lord uh
the Lord said to my Lord sit at my right
hand so you got the Lord talking to the
Lord said clearly it's God the Father
talking to God the son it's that same
God the son you see in Daniel 7 who
comes before the Ancient of
Days um so um when it says this they
have begotten you there it's really
talking about the
Incarnation uh of Jesus and of course
you have Al you you read verse eight but
verse 9 says you shall break them in you
shall break them with the rod of iron
and you shall Dash them into pieces now
that's a Messianic phrase when it talks
about a rod of iron it's also referred
to Jesus when he comes and he smites the
wicked it says with a rod of iron it
represents judgment so clearly this
passage is talking about Jesus the
Messianic phrase yeah and that's in
Revelation where it says he will smash
him as a rod well actually says in
Revelation 12 the child rules all
nations with a rod of iron The Man Child
y so yep I hope that helps a little
Lloyd and uh appreciate your question
thank you okay we've got Adrien in
California Adrien welcome to the
program thank you so much how you guys
doing always better than we deserve my
question is thank you thank you God
bless um as a Christian if someone asks
you the question are you saved what
should be your answer and should we know
will be assured that we are safe
now yeah great question well first of
all I always want to know who's asking
me the question because there's a
context if if one of my Baptist friends
says are you saved I'd say yes because
what they're asking is do you know the
Lord um if you've got an Armenian friend
and he says are you saved they're
wanting to know do you believe that once
saved always saved I'd explain to them
that you know I have confidence I know
the Lord that I am a Christian it
doesn't mean that I can't be lost and so
some of it just has to do with who's
asking you the question and what's in
inferred by that uh can we know we have
eternal life can a Christian have some
confidence well John says by this we may
know that way we have eternal life
Whoever has this Whoever has the son has
life so uh you know I I'm hoping that
that's uh answering what you're asking
Adrian but we're going to try and take
one or two more calls we're we're
running the clock's running up on us
here and we see people waiting we got
Diana Washington Diane welcome to Bible
an's live we have just a few
minutes um yeah thank you so much for
taking my call first of all um I have a
family member that's telling me that God
created sin and she's getting this from
Isaiah
457 um and she goes well it does say um
I make peace and create evil and so just
quickly I'd like your uh thoughts on
that because I don't believe that God
created sin I mean he gave when he
created Satan and created Adam and Eve
he gave us free will you know to choose
so um I would just like your thoughts on
that thank you well God is good God is
just god is perfect and God does not
create evil uh God created a beautiful
angel that became a devil this verse is
often misunderstood just because when
you go from one language to another it
can it can lose some of its meaning here
God is simply saying I am the one who
allows these judgments to come and so
the word evil there is the word
Calamity it means I can send calamity
Cal ity and when you know when God sent
a flood on the world he sent Calamity
but it was really a judgment so that's
different than evil a judgment is
actually a good thing it's bringing
Justice you know if a judge sentences
you know a violent criminal to prison
he's sending Calamity to the prisoner
but he's sending peace to the the
citizens so it's not evil it's good for
a judge to do that so th this is saying
God sends judgment all right one last
question if we can get it in we got
Richard in um New Mexico or Anie where's
Anie Nebraska Richard Nebraska the
Richard yep got just a minute hello
hi are you there yes we're here and your
question okay just real quick I let me
make it real quick because I know you
guys are running out of time but I
always wondered because uh it says in
the Bible that the devil deceived a
third of the Angels do you have any idea
and it's kind of like a silly question
but I always wondered what what was the
third of the Angels do we even have any
clue you know how many of a third of
what a million a billion right well you
know the Bible does tell us that uh he's
surrounded by an innumerable company of
angels and I think it says 10,000 he
comes with 10,000 time 10,000 now I
think thousands of thousands yeah that's
the it's basically saying that it's
countless you know God said the
descendants of Abraham would be like the
stars and like the dust of the sea so
there are billions of angels there are
guardian angels for every human alive
and so if you figure there are 8 billion
people in the world and there's at least
one Guardian Angel and there may be a
guardian and recording angels and maybe
they work in shifts there's billions of
angels and so yeah one-third of them
rebelled against God it's hard to put an
exact number on that obviously but don't
worry God is not running short on Angels
like some kings run short on soldiers
he's got uh countless angels that
minister to him if for our list
listening friends I always like a take a
moment and
explain those that are listening on
satellite radio satellite and free to
Air have two different clocks that they
use and so because of that we sign off
sort of in two stages we'll say farewell
uh and God blessed to our friends that
are listening on satellite for all the
others stand by because we are going to
be taking a couple of minutes answering
your internet questions and uh we'll be
doing as many rapid fire questions as we
can in just a couple of minutes for the
rest of our friends God bless we'll
study together again next
week thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California Hello friends and welcome
back to Bible answers live we're going
to take your email questions if you have
a question just be B questions
amazingfacts.org that's Bal questions
amazingfacts.org Pastor Doug from
Trinidad keanne is asking is Michael the
Archangel Jesus and if so what are the
scriptures yeah I remember when I first
learned this I thought how can that be
he's called an angel well it's not a
regular Angel uh one of the titles for
Jesus is Michael the Archangel and it
doesn't mean Jesus is an angel that word
Archangel it means the greatest
messenger and the Bible says the Lord
himself will descend from heaven with a
shout and the voice of the Archangel
it's the Archangel that resurrects Moses
it's the angel of the Lord that Joshua
worships and we are only to worship God
and that's in the Book of Joshua chapter
2 I think all right the verse you're
talking about the Archangel is 1
Thessalonians 4:16 it says the Lord will
come with the voice of the shout of the
Archangel correct okay next question we
have we've got uh Dennis asking where
did mlisc come from talks about him not
having a father or a mother does this
mean that he is God himself yeah when
Paul says that melkisedek is without
father or mother beginning of days he's
simply making a comparison of melkisedek
where no genealogy is given he appears
suddenly in history and disappears and
we don't know what people he's of he
said well that's like Christ who is from
eternity to Eternity has no beginning or
end but melkisedek was real person
there's just no citation of his people
or where he went what is the delusion
that God speaks about in 2 Thessalonians
chapter 2:1 where it says they do not
love the truth God sends them a strong
delusion well it's probably the same
delusion Jesus warns about when he said
that if it were possible even the very
elect would be deceived uh the devil and
three unclean spirits come out of the
mouth the Beast the dragon and the false
prophet performing signs and wonders to
deceive the leaders of the world and
bring them to that battle of Armageddon
so the nature of that delusion Satan
himself we believe is going to
impersonate Christ and talks about
bringing fire down from heaven we don't
know exactly what the particular um
Miracle is but that's why it's going to
be a delusion I think it's going to
surprise much of the
Earth all right and you know I'm looking
at the clock Pastor D we don't have time
for any more calls but we do want to
remind you you can just simply email
your question to B questions
amazingfacts.org
we're going to try and answer as many of
these at the end of each of our programs
amen don't forget check out
amazingfacts.org for a plethora of Bible
study materials and videos and then
share the link with your friends God
bless friends until next
week bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible
questions